my guess to my right who I'm thrilled to
have here on the Rich Eisen show in
person for the very first time is the
Walter Payton of the Year nominee for
your Los Angeles Rams getting set to
head to is a native Louisiana to play an
NFC Championship game for the Rams
Andrew Whitworth good to see you sir I
appreciate you having me I appreciate
you coming down here especially since
there was a possibility of rain here in
Los Angeles and I understand what that
means
yeah I thought it was kind of Louisiana
weather so they don't make an appearance
since I going down there this I got to
be honest with you I remember going on a
trip with my with my parents my family I
was about eight nine years old and I
went to New Orleans took a tour of the
Superdome and everything with my family
and it rained so hard I've never seen a
rain that hard I did so I remember this
I saw snakes coming out of the sewer
system that's a fact you know there's
not much I would doubt if you said you
saw in the world in the half pretty much
everything goes that way no it wasn't
Mardi Gras Tom either I don't believe I
don't think my family my folks would
have taken me to New Orleans during
Mardi Gras but at any rate it's a big
trip coming up for you before we get to
that I do want to hit you on the game
from from from Saturday night and what
went viral quite a bit was you hugging
your kids on the sidelines your first
career playoff win after all those years
of trying to get one what was that
moment like for you Andrew it was
amazing I didn't think that the SIL the
deal would be Jared golf making a play
with his feet quite right that wasn't my
vote for how it started happening but
you know what him got big first down
there we were able to run the clock out
and it was a it was an awesome just
watching those seconds tick down and
realize that it finally happened after
13 years to trying to get one it was an
awesome feeling and then obviously the
kids were just so excited this week and
they were pumped and and that you know
they wanted it as bad as anything and so
right that's the first people I looked
for when it ended because I knew I knew
they'd be I knew my wife and Alyssa and
the kids would be running down to get on
the field and it was also my counted
four of them right oh yeah four of them
all of them that they looked can I guess
like are they're all for under ten for
hundra
yeah so it's twin seven year olds a six
year old and a four year olds
that's fun halfway to Phillip Rivers and
so again just hugging those kids and
having that that moment in the books for
you what was it like taking this journey
and not having one one to this point in
time you know it was tough I mean I've
been on a lot of good football teams had
a lot of great regular-season records
you know a lot of expectations and just
haven't you know yet had where we put
that full team effort together and got
it done in the playoffs and obviously
having a bad week was amazing being a 37
year old offensive lineman it was good
to get a little rest right and you know
what I thought we played that way we
looked fresh and and you know what it
was just amazing just to go out and play
that way and really when you have a plan
together and you go out you execute it
exactly how you thought you would it
doesn't happen that often in the league
and man just what an exciting night and
then running for 273 yards I mean that
that and and also zero sacks of your of
your quarterback and we heard it keep
Talib jump into a live television at one
point talking about stealing Souls and
things of that nature and others were
making reference that that could be some
sort of heaven can wait Warren Beatty
reference but I doubt that heavily that
was in reference what the Cowboys had
said all week correct yeah there was
just some chatter about that and just
different people that you know we're
kind of looking to see whether we'd be
able to perform the way we had in the
regular season and you know there was
some comments about whether the line
would play well and those kind of things
and so we had you know we incentivize
ourselves I mean obviously you go out in
those games and you're gonna play the
best to your abilities no matter what
right but obviously when you hear those
things and like I say as players we go
out every week and people can comment
publicly on whether they think we played
well or not and it's people in the media
if you make a comment you get to be held
accountable as well so you know that's
that's kind of how we felt we felt the
Cowboys made some comments and some
others did as well and we just kind of
felt like it's a great moment to kind of
say hey we're here so there really is
something in the 21st century's bulletin
board material well I think we're
Twitter board material I think you think
about it this way and I thought to me
it's like be careful publicly how you go
about things it's like nowadays that can
dictate a lot of our week
so right so if somebody in the media
that has a big following says something
about a guy that I know puts them down
and who they are as a player then me and
my everyday life going in the grocery
store going to store I got to hear it
from people and fans like this person
said about this but you so it's not
really as much as that it's out there on
the media is it's about now you've kind
of like this is something that I've got
to listen to people constantly chirping
my ear about so I'm irritated you know
what I mean and so that's really where I
think more players take it is that you
know it is it's social media it's for
all public to hear so when you announce
it like that it gives the opportunity
that you know what that's what I'm I
have to here every day so if I prove
you're wrong I'm gonna let you hear
about it so you're saying and while
you're shopping I'm gonna see if I can
do this
without naming names here so while
you're shopping somebody with a cart
that says the offensive line of the Rams
is a remaining liability in the playoffs
that's something you're gonna take to
the bank well you're just gonna keep
remembering because you know if I walk
in the grocery store and I'm just trying
to grab a bottle of ketchup for the kids
right yeah somebody comes up to me and
says man don't be a liability like
so-and-so said this own Twitter
yesterday well that happened oh yeah you
hear that stuff all the time my wife
gets so magic isn't she that's why I
don't go shopping with her because if
somebody makes like I don't hold this
week all right don't get another you
know whatever the penalty I mean I have
to literally like restrain her from
going after them I'm like I'm not going
with you in public places because you
get so mad oh she's fiery now she's
alright but she's got your back in the
same way yeah no problem with it I think
it's great you know that's the way hey
that's what didn't use L go out somebody
that one time after a Super Bowl
question she can Tom can't throw it and
catch it yeah buddy
but again just did I guess put a button
on this conversation here this part of
our conversation Tom Brady coming on
after the win over the Chargers in
saying everybody thinks we suck you know
and so we'll see I mean somebody with as
many trophies in the cases he has and
rings on his fingers as he has is using
something that somebody said on
television that's what we're driven by
right I mean you you know you can't run
as fast as this guy you can't make as
much money as this guy you can't have
the kind of career
this player has their score as many
points whatever it is I mean we're
always driven but what we can't told we
can't do I mean that's that's your
nature because I guess if you really
think about you're the 1% of the world
and you've been overcoming odds your
entire life to be able to play this
sport where people said it's not likely
you can do it well my issue with it is
this and this is my end of it and
nobody's gonna cry a river over this nor
should you it also is that I try and do
this job from this microphone where the
metric of the show like this is measured
in a way about my opinions and whether
I'm a ride or not and I will always say
what's from my heart and my gut and I
will always do it in a respectful way
cuz I'm not gonna be some sort of hot
taker for the hot takers then to then
say stuff and just throw it against the
wall and have that then parroted by
players who are like see I told you so
that you were wrong you're kind of
giving them what they want yeah
confirmation that they're being heard
I'm more I'd rather be right than being
told that I'm heard and I think a lot of
folks in my business would rather be
heard than be right I think that's a
safe assumption so you're not gonna help
me out in any way shape all those people
out there me no I know I'm not asking
for your help but you know you see what
I'm saying I agree with you 100% agree
with you there's a lot of people that
just rather be heard Andrew Whitworth
here on the Rich Eisen show ok so now
it's not just you being motivated by
what you hear or what you you feel you
need to prove it's also being smart and
it's also study your your your colleague
on the line and Austin Blythe might have
given up a little bit of a ghost here or
not I don't know but did you know what
the Rams that the Cowboys defensive line
was doing stunting wise based on a tell
that you picked up on film yeah I would
say every week really you come in with a
plan for the team you're playing and
really what you see them do and and I
don't think that's really you know
something just telling about the Cowboys
in the sense of that I think what he
kind of means is like what we'd study
with them and the different looks and
where people were in the formations and
those kind of things that you know
there's certain things that you gain
plan to be able to do
and sometimes as linemen especially we
can get a feel for guys depending on how
they play normally whether they you know
do different things and throughout the
you know course of a game and you're
like oh you know what I kind of can fill
this out of his stance or I can fill
this out how he's lining up on me that
this is what he wants to do I mean
that's just kind of a in the game I
guess probably something most people
don't think about cuz that's kind of an
inline play type thing I mean just what
happens yeah sure I mean when you're
certainly when you're taking on a
stunting team like the Dallas Cowboys it
would be helpful to know where the
stunts coming from or when it might be
attempted and you know Blythe was saying
that based on where Malik Collins was
lining up and where the rest of the
defensive linemen were putting that
which hand they were putting in the dirt
90% of the time you could tell what was
coming so I think sometimes the interior
guys can get a fill that on the edge III
just have to you know worry about him
running around the corner must assure
him so I'm a little more worried about
how they're get off and those kind of
things but yeah I mean there might have
been some tails that he had there but I
think that's something more you know of
who you're playing exactly in the film
study you do and I'll you know just good
job by him having kind of a feel for the
guy he's playing what a CJ Anderson
brought to the equation here oh man I
mean just a physicality that has been
special I mean you felt in these last
few weeks I mean it's man to believe
that guy's been that was at home and and
not on a team is just unbelievable he
said he told Dan Patrick earlier today
he thought the season was over when the
Raiders cut him and that he was over
that he thought that he wasn't gonna
play football at all and now he's
playing some serious meaningful snaps
for a team that has superbowl
aspirations that's two wins away from
actually lifting that trophy I mean he
and girly or are a one-two punch that I
think you guys did not had previously
with all due respect to the rest of the
roster would you agree with that
assumption I mean the way he's play
there's no doubt about it I mean those
two guys that the match they are of his
physicality with the football in his
hand and Todd's speed and agility and
just the nature of what a great player
he is I mean when you add those one-two
punches you know people are tired and
have to chase Todd or they're tired and
got to tackle him and get him on the
ground I think that they right now are
playing very well off each other and
give us something that we haven't had
throughout the season what's the cheat
no it's the challenge with the Saints
here
you well I think obviously those guys
that you know that they're tremendous on
offense and and you know and and they do
a really good job defensively the last
half the season and you know I think
both of us are a little different teams
and probably were when we played in week
nine and I think the opportunity for us
to go out execute offensively and be
able to run the football it's gonna be
important but you know what also just as
a team I mean this is one of those games
that you got to expect you're gonna get
the best of each other so you know it's
it's really not gonna be about hey we
gotta go perform it's gonna be we got to
play our best till the final tick these
get these championship games always come
down to just something at the end and so
it's really gonna be about not only
trying to perform your best being
prepared but realizing you're gonna have
to do it for 60 straight minutes and
you've gotten your your schedule for the
week already right oh you schedule it
because obviously Shaun McVeigh has got
it all down to the second was there I
don't you can not give away any any
inside information but was there
anything on the list there allotting
time for Marcus Peters to have some
gumbo with Sean Payton I don't know you
know what we get a little free time on
Saturday so maybe maybe they'll have a
look at a little bit of reunion it's
truly one of my favorite sound bites of
the entire the entire week would you
mind loading that up right now
go for it roller frangie Wentworth here
for you we're Sean Payton said after
that New Orleans game he said in that
last sequence we wanted if they got the
matchup they wanted with you on him Sean
Payton keep talking it we don't see him
soon you feeling fair enough
yeah because I liked what he was saying
on the sidelines too so I'll tell you
keep talking it and I hope you see me
soon you feel me
and then we don't have a good look nice
love all of gumbo together yeah it's
gumbo week let's see it he deleted this
but he's ready to go yeah you know
that's my guy man so you know what he's
a little prophetic right I mean he did
say that I mean then it's true that is
true so at least be checked
yeah we can check that and I don't know
whether they'll actually gumbo together
but we'll see so it's not actually on
the list it's not a formal setup yeah
happening but you know how things go I
mean you can text one another and just
meet up and grab some gum where would be
the best place in New Orleans for that
do you know off the top of your head
give me a lot of trouble if I named one
cuz they'd all be offended okay I don't
want to get you in you know what I think
there's plenty of places in New Orleans
to find some Guilbeau okay uh you were
on the LSU bcs national championship
team for Nick Saban at the loss a day at
LSU were you not sir I was
did he recruit you personally Nick Saban
yeah I was his first recruiting class mm
what was that like for you basically he
was coming out of Michigan State at
Ellington I was actually at that time
kind of decided I was gonna go to
Florida and play for Spurrier and Nick
was signed to LSU and I changed my mind
and decided to be a tiger and you know
did you call Spurrier and personally
deliver that news no I did not but IIIi
not formally committed I was in the
process I'd visited there and kind of
thought that was gonna do and then Nick
came in and I met with him over the
summer and really just you know from day
one rails this guy's pretty special and
how is that why is that just you know I
think there's certain people you meet in
coaching that just through a
conversation I understand how they see
ball how they see the big picture of the
process how you go about being
successful at something it's bigger than
just X's and O's and whether we're gonna
win or lose it's about man this guy has
a process day in and day out that he's
gonna go about to be successful and it
something that just cleans you to him
the moment you sit down with him and
I've always said this not that Sean has
had that kind of success at all but I've
said since I've been there that Sean is
one of the first people I've been around
like that that just immediately you can
sit and talk with him and you get a feel
like with Nick that man this guy's daily
process rhythm how he goes about working
and being successful is just different
it's different yeah you know I was gonna
ask you about that as to is there any
similarities obviously they're from
different generations and obviously he
like you just one first career playoff
game so obviously there's some brake
pumping that you need to do when you
talk about Sean McVeigh at this point in
time but you could tell I could tell
when I met him at the combine when he
had just gotten the job almost two years
ago at this point in time he actually
was the anniversary of his two years of
his hiring was the night of the
over the cowboys you could tell there's
something there is their similarity in
any way but really the intensity really
just the the obviously both of them are
extremely intelligent guys but the
intensity day in and day out that just
never changes never wavers never a
win-lose good day bad day has nothing to
do with how they're gonna go about their
job every single day at the same
intensity and there's never never want
to be like okay today he's not you know
in the mood or today's kind tired and
he's gonna let someone else know I mean
it's just everyday that intensity level
is that as a thousand percent and and I
you know it's you almost just sit there
and go manage no way he can be that way
all time he's gonna work out but I mean
I've said that about Nick since I was
there which was seventeen years ago so
how often you in contact with him at all
not much but I told somebody this in the
day so you know what Nick and I haven't
talked since he left LSU to go to the
Dolphins and I have zero doubt that you
know it would be weird I'd walk in there
and it would be like we'd seen each
other day before I mean I always had a
respect for him and and I was one of his
guys when he was there and and you know
that's kind of how I've done most of my
career just the process I go about
things and how I do things or a lot of
that influence came from him well and
obviously you know what you do and how
you go about Andrew Whitworth is people
are gonna be watching you there was one
play that I saw on the Twitterverse as
well that really jumped out was on the
field goal that Zuerlein attempted from
damn near the parking lot at the end of
the first half
the one person who ran down the field
just in case it was gonna get returned
the person who beat everybody down the
field that was that was you are you
aware of those sorts of things when
you're attempting them or is that just
innate free yeah it is a little bit
unaware at the same time I mean to me
it's always about opportunities and
leadership to show how important things
are to you and to make sure that you
always are a tone setter in my family
with my wife and the kids and all that
we always talked about that like just
when we walk in a place where we go
somewhere we want to be tone setters in
the sense of like just being positive
and being somebody that people are like
man we want to be around these people
because I mean I think people see
leadership and things a lot of different
ways in my opinion the greatest leaders
are people that you want to walk in a
room with not that you want to listen to
so my point is is like yeah I can give
you like somebody could say hey these
guys
your leader gives me advice but the
reality is if like there are really a
truly great leader if like you're like
you know what that's the person I want
to be around every day because I'm a
better version of myself when I'm around
them and to me that's like what I try
every day obviously I'll make plenty of
mistakes but to me it's like I want to
have a conscious mind of like hey who do
I want to be you know when people are
saying hey is this the guy want to look
up to is this guy want to be on the line
with is this guy won't be a teammate
with am I trying to do my best to be
that version you know and just
constantly questioning myself on that
well that's no surprise than that you're
the Walter Payton Man of the Year
nominee so good luck on that and then do
you spend last one for you Andrew
Whitworth just even a split-second
daydreaming about what's like winning
two more in a row there's no question
yeah I spend a lot of time thinking
about that and how much it mean I mean
obviously this weekend alone it's a
special place I mean you mentioned the
national championship that's that's is
actually the Superdome is where a woman
was right the Sugar Bowl and also won
three state championships there so in
high school so you're feeling good
walking in that so I you know what the
dome was a really special place to me
and somewhere that I'm a majority my
athletic career a lot of the
accomplishments I have happened in that
building and so obviously it's a really
special place to me and and somewhere
that I said after we lost their last
time just I thought that might be the
last time I get to play there that man
what a place I'll always remember how
special it is to me and my family and
what I've been able to accomplish there
so are you just are you saying you're
contemplating retirement no I'm not but
you know you sir know when you're gonna
go back so I when we lost there and we
cannot I wasn't real sure whether we
have the season will play out or how
next year would play out whether we'd be
going there they come to us so you know
what I didn't know if I'd be back so I'm
I'm glad to be back
didn't you hear from Marcus Peters since
your ago I should have listened to him I
didn't realize there was a gumbo
appointment now I did it you feel me I
mean you feel me I mean come on no I
feel you okay very good at a Whitworth
77 on Twitter as well on Instagram good
to see you Andrew well thanks for coming
down here you got an off day during
between divisional and in conference
action really appreciate you stopping by
in person I appreciate it rich you got
that's Andrew Whitworth of the Los
Angeles
Rams getting set to go back to his
hometown to try and head to Atlanta to
win it all that's right here on the Rich
Eisen show you know Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience